sì
benvenuti stranita stylist oggi vivremo
una fantastica giornata assieme sarà
come fare una bellissima vacanza tutti
assieme per che passeremo 24 ore in
giardino e quella del video fino alla
fine perchè stanotte guarderemo le
stelle assieme sarà come fare un
campeggio tutti assieme per prima cosa
dobbiamo mettere la tenda nel giardino
manda lasciate un bel mi piace se volete
altre sole 24 ore se questo video rose
di 30 mila mi piace faremo un'altra
soling 24 ore
scrivete voi nei commenti che altro
challenge e volete che facciamo era
siete pronti a iniziare questo
campeggiato a noi
prendete i pop corn mettetevi comodi e
iniziamo subito la salle
[Musica]
che la tenda è pronta
entriamo per la prima volta nella tenda
e vediamo come dobbiamo ancora arredarla
e portare un po di cose dentro
e così qualche bello e bella spaziosa
molto confortevole mi sento ben riparata
al sicuro e berlino che strano che non è
ancora arrivato a distruggere la tenda
ci sono se la finestra
devo andare ad aprirla da fuori che si
senta un po più fresca e gestu per
rilassante
ecco qua d'italia ha aperto la finestra
ora iniziamo a portare un po di cose
dentro la tenda così diventa ancora più
carina e confortevole e poi apprendiamo
che si entra senza buttare che cosa
potrei portare nella nostra tenda per il
nostro campeggio magari prendo un po di
pupazzi così faranno un po da cuscino
questa è una lanterna
anche se la useremo stanotte festa una
bellissima dan terna per fare pazzie la
lente no no no no berlino no no no no
berlino adora mangiare i pupazzi neo
merlino non si mangia questi avrà
scavato nuovamente mi sembra che manchi
ancora qualcosa è un po troppo vuota
questa tenda cosa potrei aggiungere
comunque berlino è il molto tutto sporco
di terra perché lui sotterrossi la prima
volta che l'ha visto vitale ha detto non
ci posso credere pensavo che succedesse
sono i cartoni animati in pezzetti merli
nostra terra gli orsi perché ha paura
che qualcuno glieli ruby ma chi potrebbe
rubargli sicuramente non in orbita
[Musica]
bene 3 pupazzetti sistemati hanno fatto
dire due berlino è un pupazzone però non
so cos'altro portare qua dentro ma
adesso andiamo a preparare il pranzo al
sacco che si possiamo pranzare assieme
cioè non so se voi avete già apprezzato
ma possiamo pranzare assieme
ti piace gui merlina se il comodo sporco
[Musica]
berlino si sta rilassando nella tenda
nuova assieme ai suoi due nuovi amici si
e minaccia nei primi 6 giu stanco ho
messo a dormire
e un po presto per dire sai ora dobbiamo
guardare berlino sta già dormendo
stanchissimi
ecco vitale che non infrange sacramento
che cosa ti sei portato da mangiare ma
veramente io pensavo che tu preparati
anche per me io ho preparato tutto per
me come quelli che sono per te è
arrivato anche berlino per mangiare i
pupazzi berlino
sto scherzando un è per te ieri e meno
male per merlino e per berlino lui
merlino mangia stasera berlino mi sa che
si voleva andare tutto il mio pranzo
sicuramente mangerà qualcosa guarda il
video un po cosa abbiamo per pranzo con
preparazioni tale
non vedo l'ora merlino proverà a rubarci
tutto il cibo che sta per chi ha preso
non so niente e farfalle sentiamo
campeggio perché ci sia questa è la
pasta crudaiola è una delle mie piste
preferite
allora in pratica ci sono pomodorini ha
detto posto aiutavano in campeggio con
un cane
voi siete voi stasera un pezzo e con un
cane scrive rotazione di cosa stavano
dicendo questa fame mangia con i
pomodorini le olive taggiasche io adoro
le olive ne mangiò tipo barato l'inter
in america ha messo il formaggio
vegetale buon appetito
ma perito disperato ma c'è anche il
basilico i pomodori da poco da una solo
per avere la vostra pasta preferita la
mia preferita e gli spaghetti aglio
peperoncino
potremmo andar lì ogni giorno io adoro
troppo sono troppo buoni e la tua io
dovrò tutta la pasta però il formato che
mi piace di più sono le mezze maniche
come le magliette e gli spaghetti gli
spaghetti li adoro tantissimi noi due
litighiamo sempre perché io voglio
sempre gli spaghetti e quindi andiamo
sempre spaghetti appunto finito passiamo
al secondo ma allora che cosa abbiamo
abbiamo le carote da inzuppare qui con
con questa salsa allo yogurt e poi il
fragole e banane a berlino sta tornando
a mangiarsi tutto e poi qua dentro
in questo cosiddetto qui c'è la sorpresa
il dessert del sera a sorpresa
berlino berlino sta cercando di rubare è
arrivata godzilla vai al posto tuo dai
seduto allora mi rendo abbiamo la
macedonia le carote lo yogurt e fa
non so cosa hanno ascoltato quello che
diciamo bravo di me e sulle mie spalle
così alla prima distrazione è pronto più
belle minuto ci dispiace un sacco per le
persone che hanno passato questa 41
stanno passando questa quarantena in un
appartamento non hanno magari un
giardino un piccolo balcone
sappiamo cosa significa perché abbiamo
sempre vissuto un appartamento a prima
anzi abbiamo anche vissuto in un
appartamento che era talmente piccolo
che era solo una stanza solo una stanza
con un bagno periamo che con questo
video vi sentiate un po con noi nel
nostro giardino fare questa mini vacanza
campeggia con vitale che mangia tutto
buono qual è il vostro frutto preferito
il mio lamela le fragole e le ciliegie
so qual è il vostro futuro ferito tutti
i buoni
puoi scegliere il tuo giu la mela il
porto prefetto di berlino è senza dubbio
la mela infatti siamo uguali io e lui se
ci seguite su instagram se non sia
seguita in dote a seguirci il nome
nalità stories potrete vedere mio gesto
rischi e merlino impazzisce per le mele
infatti il suo soprannome melino oppure
berlin do perché in posticiparne mele
non so perché vediamo un po cosa m
valdentro vitale secondo dai però
berlino non lo so
cioccolato o no vi voglio tu non lo vuoi
mangiare merlino se mangi quei tumori
che stai andando cioccolato fondente
loro porco comodo ma perché vuoi cadere
le cose dalla bocca quando mangi mastica
con la bocca aperta ok ora che abbiamo
pranzato giochiamo a qualcosa
giochiamo a nascondino o un due tre
stella o tre stelle vi ho letto da poco
che in realtà un due tre stella non è
stella ma è un 23 stai la sono rimasta
scioccata quando ho letto qui che
versione conoscete un due tre stella o
un 23 styla scrivetelo nei commenti
iniziamo a giocare e inizia a contare
pure 23 bella ti ho visto muoverti
rinviate berlino dovete tornare indietro
tutte e 21 23
stella bravi devo dire che siete stati
bravi 123 ce l'ha
berlino berlino profitti e vabbè dai
glielo perdono questa volta ora 23 vela
[Musica]
[Risate]
vabbè dai berlino e glielo perdono dai
123 x edizione vicinissimo ai perso
perché ti sei vostro torna indietro
una due tre stella berlino sotto
bravissimo ti ha superato una due tre
come hai fatto così vicino due private
adesso tocca a loro ha vinto 12 berlino
pure due indietro forza 123 sera ti ho
visto uno due tre stella merlino un po
state fermi lì tutti e due e falso ora
due tre stella brava pure lui e ti ho
vista dura 2 3
come è comoda me la posizione che stai
facendo
la lanciatrice del disco
no no no non si arriva da te può essere
amici tenico essenziale di berlino gli
diamo un premietto ragazzi siamo
arrivati alla nocciola che come potete
vedere da qua dietro il buio
abbiamo la cena qua berlino sto cercando
di rubarci la ovviamente allora cosa
abbiamo in questo se letta descrivi un
po allora ci abbiamo queste qua che sono
un po oscure che non si vedono e sono
delle melanzane grigliate
noi abbiamo le patatine fritte m due
fette di pane 6 meta perfetta per il
nostro campeggio in giardino appetito
c'è merlino che ci sta guardando con
aria ci sta guardando in cagnesco
[Musica]
ma non era cosa sdraiato qui con me sono
buonissime queste milan zone io adoro il
mondo
ed ecco qua merlino che fa la guardia
all'entrata della tenda in il nostro
bravissimo cagnolino controlla chi sia
tutto ok ho acceso la lanterna e poi
abbiamo la ricordate in questa lanterna
ci sono le stelline questo prezzo per
karina modo a fare una passeggiatina con
berlino andiamo a cercare dei frutti
rari oppure del cibo ma è appena finito
di mangiare tanto noi siamo sempre
automatico indietro va bene andate pure
io faccio un riposino visto che tardi
siamo rimaste solo di due ma ora io sono
stanca quindi faccio un riposino
spegniamo le luci questa lampada non c'è
ancora troppa luce uffa vengo anche
questa come fai a tenere la candela in
mano perché in realtà è una candela a
batterie non so se riuscite a vederlo
vedete per quello che non mi brucia
preferisco questo così non rischio di
bruciare tutto spento anche questa fa
c'è ancora troppa luce
mi è venuta un'idea chiudo questa porta
qua chiuso la porta principale
così ci sarà un ok sono riuscite a
chiudere la porta principale
adesso posso fare un riposino come
cuscino
userò uno dei due pupazzi vediamo se
riesco a stare comoda qua e ora dormo un
pochettino ok
cerchiamo donna
[Musica]
vitale 1 vitale si allontana tra sono
rimasto proprio da sola ma mi sembra di
sentire dei rumori strani forse solo il
fatto che sono rimasto da solo e mi sto
un po condizionando un po di paura ma mi
sembra di sentire dei rumori strani e
sentiti anche i poverini
avete sentito che quello che sembravo
tipo un urlo
[Musica]
qua
così
[Musica]
mondo
tutto ciò c'è merlino
i piani sbrigati che se qualcuno fuori
riina forse mi farà la guardia adesso
sono molto contenta che è tornato vero
pitale ancora non è tornato
ok marino tu devi proteggermi occhiali
hai sentito anche tumori strani devi pro
servizio di occhiali berlino berlino
aiutami tu che c'è qualcosa di strano
proteggimi tu
[Musica]
sul cambiamento
cercando di entrare ok chiudiamo
chiediamo e chiediamo
la maschera
per togliere la massima
era tutto lo sai che mi sono spaventato
tantissimo
[Musica]
dovevo pensarci in effetti se vitale era
sparito mi avrebbe combinato una delle
sue come dovrei spingermi commerciale
scritta in commenti come dovrebbe
indicarmi se questori che raggiunge il
30 mila mi piace però io una bella
vendetta vitale consigliatemi qualche
cosa niente un bel niente ora devo
riposarmi visto che i miei zii ora non
riesco più a dormire bene questa è stata
la nostra avventura 24 ore in giardino
intenda io sono ancora arrabbiata con
vitale per avermi fatto questo scherzo
super spaventoso adesso devo dormire e
sentito che questo amore che ho sentito
prima un verso non eri tu no lasciamo
qua quattro case lines qwerty carpreaux
degli altri video mentre noi chiudiamo
subito la porta e ci proteggiamo come di
nola che preferite e buona visione
ciao
[Musica]